find the probability of pulling a yellow
marble from a bag with three yellow to
red to green and one blue I'm assuming
marbles so they say the probability I'll
just say P for probability the
probability of picking a yellow yellow
marble and so this is sometimes the
event in question right over here is
picking the yellow marble I'll even
write down the word picking and when you
say probability it's really just a way
of measuring the likelihood that it's
something is going to happen and the way
we're going to think about it is how
many of the outcomes from this trial
from this picking a marble out of a bag
how many meet our constraints satisfy
this event and and how many possible
outcomes are there so let me write the
possible outcomes right over here so
possible possible possible outcomes and
you'll see it's actually a very
straightforward idea but I'll just make
sure that we understand all the words
that people might say so the set of all
the possible outcomes well there's three
yellow marbles so I could pick that
yellow marble that yellow marble or that
yellow marble that yellow marble these
are clearly all yellow there's two red
marbles in the bag so I could pick that
red marble or that red marble there's
two green marbles in the bag so I could
pick that green marble or that green
marble and then there's one blue marble
in the bag there's one blue marble so
this is all the possible outcomes and
sometimes this is referred to as the
sample space sample the set of all the
possible outcomes fancy word for just a
simple idea that the sample space if
when I pick something out of the bag and
that picking out of the bag is called a
trial there's eight possible things I
can do so when I think about the
probability of picking a yellow marble I
want to think about well what are all of
the possibilities well there's eight
possibilities eight possibilities for my
trial so the number of outcomes number
of possible outcomes you could view it
as the size of the sample space number
of possible outcomes and it's as simple
as saying well look I have eight marbles
and then you say well how many of those
marbles meet my constraint that satisfy
this event
here well there's three marbles that
satisfy my event there's three outcomes
that that will allow this event to occur
I guess is one way to say it so there's
three right over here so a number that
satisfy satisfy the the event or the
constraint right over here so it's very
simple ideas all many times the words
make them more complicated than they
need to if I say what's the probability
of picking a yellow marble
well how many different types of marbles
can I pick well there's eight different
marbles I could pick and then how many
of them are yellow well there's three of
them that are actually yellow